does the new man have now to your child
from another
man
would you like like what like does he
take on all of the responsibility as a
father
or is there some kind of halfway
dad situation going on
does that make sense because a lot of
women
have
expect a man for instance there was a
viral video this week you know a couple
of days ago where this woman
was she had a father of her child she
had three other children and he came to
bring his child every day lunch and then
she was like oh i've got three other
kids and he's like those ain't my kids
i've got one with you i don't have an
obligation to look after your children
so i'm just like do women who already
have children think that their new man
or another man has the obligation to
look after the children that aren't his
i think it depends on if you're dating
or if you're or if you're taking things
serious i think it depends if you're
dating they don't need to see your child
you're just you know dating and doing
your thing but if you are building with
you you're moving on and you're building
with that person you're gonna you know
get engaged get married have children
and stuff it that kind of comes with
that kind of you you kind of see how
they build their own relationship as
well i feel i feel like you do group
stuff you go out to eat you do whatever
you need to do
you know and you see if that when you're
doing the introducing after six months
or after a year you see if your child
how they are with that person you need
to see if they if they've got that
relationship you can't force you can't
force it
is he allowed to discipline your child
um
it depends on that situation see this is
the thing because
because
yeah
i was in a relationship for like 10
years right and when i was in that
relationship i was with a woman who
already had a child
we had a child together but what was
very um
very apparent to me within that
relationship was that i was not allowed
to discipline this child the way i could
discipline my own child right because a
child still had the father in their life
the father would have something to say
about it if i disciplined the child in a
certain way and so
i i
there's a lot of men out here saying
that they wouldn't get with a woman a
lot of men say they wouldn't get with a
woman who already has a child because
you get a lot of the benefits
sorry you don't get all of the benefits
of being a father
right but you have the responsibility as
a father so it's like
what is the incentive for men
to actually get with women who actually
already have children when you know that
at some point in time you are going to
be reminded that that child ain't yours
i'm going to be controversial and say i
think the father should
look after the kid
they're better off statistically yeah
kids are better off after the age of
like eight with their fathers over their
mothers especially even financially like
single fathers tend to be better with
money than single mothers oh wait no i'm
talking about my i i think the the step
dad should look after the
the step kid oh the steps yeah okay
the reason why i say this is because
you're picking the woman
you know she's got a kid already so you
you should assume that you're gonna have
to look after her kid even though she
might not want you to that's it's like
you're picking the woman not the child
no but you know she's got a child so
you're picking the woman and the child
if it's not just to marry her yeah like
it's like you're
she's not going to step she's not going
to like um put the kid up for adoption
like it's like no you know they're
coming as a pair so you got to prepare
yourself already to be like you know
what i might not be able to discipline
him the way that i want to i'm somebody
i know i'm gonna have to pay for his
this i'm gonna have to pay for that i'm
gonna have to pay for that i know i'm
gonna have to get this in my air about
how you talking to him please talk to me
instead of talking to the kid and i know
you're gonna get that but i think i
think that um stepdads should be allowed
to discipline the kids because yeah
because like
it's what he's signing up for if he's
going to take on the responsibility he
should get
it
was your fault allow you to do it though
that's not your child that's my child
i'll discipline the child yeah they're
nine times out of ten that's what
mothers will do
is they disagree though the door's there
no i think
if it's not natural it's not organic you
can't fool someone into obligation if
you do that it builds resentment and
that's like coercive control that's like
mental abuse and women complain about
that all the time and what i notice as
well with the women i know that's like
that they're um usually hypocritical
it's double standards they they can do
that kind of parent said oh well he's
not my child if the father has one
already but if we do that it's a big
problem
this is where this is what i just
disagree with yeah that's what but
that's why men like oftentimes don't get
involved with single moms because it's
just it's too confusing for them i'm
allowed to
do this but not that and i'm taking on
the responsibility but i don't get any
of the authority
and that's why a lot of times they come
out and say it's a bad deal and you know
what that does for children
children even if you've got like two
children one's yours and one's not yours
that other child sees
that that child gets treated differently
right and so
that child one of the children know that
if they're left with stepdad they can
probably get away with a little bit more
than they could if it was actual dad do
you know what i mean and so they'll push
the boundaries listen up trust me i've
been there yeah i've been there like
they will push the boundaries there
because they know you can't discipline
me like my mom can disagree or my dad
can discipline me
you say that you say that in my
experience obviously i'm not saying this
for everybody but in my experience my
first mother
her eldest favored me
at one point he drew me in place of his
dad in his primary school book
and all because i gave him routine and
structure i wasn't too pally pally with
him i said look this is the boundaries
you're stressing out your mother you've
got a certain bedtime you have to go to
bed
he said you need to help her out because
i said a lot of the time she's running
around and you're capable he was he
could die in his clothes he's good at
folding so i said you need to give him a
bit more responsibility and what i found
amazing at the time i thought he
despised me but he actually started we
started to get really good on and in a
second
i think because he's dead one actually
around
he favored me as well so that that
middle one actually handed me better
than my own son but you know that's what
a lot of people see that they will see
that and they'll say that as a bad thing
not knowing that you're actually helping
the you
so to be fair he's mother she actually
liked it she encouraged it which i found
was a bit peculiar so she was he the
first one
so we're talking about like women that
don't want their partner to discipline
the kid
so like even when he's like being a man
in the house and being like
pick up that and whatever like she might
not like it but he might like it like
when i grew up with a stepdad my mom
wouldn't know like certain times like do
you know what i mean i'd be like raw
like now i'm looking back i'm like
this man is amazing bro like do you know
what i mean like he took me on as a step
son
and
treated me like all his other children
and did you push the boundaries of him
knowing that was you was your actual
biological dad around
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a bit of a
rich dad poor dad like
so basically i was brought up in
trinidad and england and trinidad and
england right my dad was here my stepdad
was in trinidad right over my mom
and
he was muslim
so i was on the
militant
is style you know i'm saying without
without the terrorism part but you know
what i'm trying to say like five times a
day like ramadan everything ready but
i'm saying when i look back at that now
that was discipline bro
do you know what i mean i wouldn't see
as that i would be like right this bread
is so annoying like who do you think he
is my dad do you think my dad do you
think times have changed now though
like do you think times have changed
like children do you think children show
step
fathers and mothers
adults in general the same respect that
they did when you were growing up it
depends on who's the parent yeah it
depends and the character of the child
as well yeah
depending on the parent bro it's just
statistically now it's a lot of single
parents so it's
skewed because at the end of the day
we we tell men avoid single mothers
yeah even though some men i i don't say
that i say i i don't tell them to avoid
supermarkets i say up to a certain age
a man should build for himself and if
he's going to get with a woman it should
be a single woman with no women no
children i feel like people with kids
should just date each other like that's
yeah and that's also an option but i'm
saying if you get once you get to a
certain age generally
women are going to have one or two
children if you get like past the age of
30 and looking for a woman she's
probably gonna have a child or two so
you're gonna have to decide what you're
gonna do but below the age of 30 i don't
think any man should be getting with a
woman with children you say that but i
always find i'm about 27 28 if they
don't have a child already or at least
been in a serious relationship i start
thinking are they weirdos
by what age 27 28 if i haven't had a
long-term relationship or they have an
editing children i think what's wrong
with them so yeah about excuse me
in this society now really and truly i
personally believe you don't really know
yourself until you're about
late twenties
statistically fifty percent of women
over thirty are single and childless
and um but that kind of goes into
another stat which is like one out of
three women making over forty seven
thousand dollars per year has had an
abortion so there's a good chance to me
that maybe they were pregnant at one
point but what do you say that's a
cultural thing because in the uk my
sphere of influence i've seen most women
have children already you so i mean so
before the age of 30 mostly women
maybe run in different circles
that jamaican circle
yeah
way
maybe